hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my legend Korra episode 7 video
at think we just found the moment where
everyone
where the world is gonna turn again
school year a the fandom as well as the
world
inside a pledge to cora everybody needs
to give the team break
a high five for making everyone cry
because they're happy
in cry because they're really really
scared does the quote-unquote balance in
this episode
really sad but happy moments in one
giant sad scary moment
good reminder new giveaway starts right
now are you to do to enter is be a
subscriber in leave a comment on this
video
but careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet starting with top
five moments
number five core returns to Air Temple
Island the dirty release the clip
really early this summer reuniting with
Noga probably the saddest thing ever
if any you guys have big dogs to you'll
understand why this was
such a cry where the moment it also
answered wear poppies been this whole
time and everyone's been asking about
where he's been in book four clearly
just chilling with Noga
I was pretty certain after the rescue at
the end the last episode that they be
heading back to your temple alan is
because that's where tendon is
as much as other characters have evolved
past them in terms of spiritual
abilities like
genera tenzin is still the character
everyone goes to for advice
he's a good dad by proxy for team Korea
which is why I was really happy when
he didn't blame core up for all the bad
things that I'm going on
not the neighbors think that he would
the observed was all about reunions
this was just the first to many number
four team core reunion part 1
so first we have the course I me reunion
and everyone keeps asking about them
it's on the subtext you could take
whatever you want from it this remember
this is a kids show
on a bike on Channel I definitely love
chords reaction to Prince moved the way
he inserts himself
as I get fit WI on their relationship
between my going to Saami
ever bomber the court did not write to
Marco
I think he's right to be outraged I mean
I'd be pretty pissed
just remember that book for is all about
evolving as a character it's been three
years
so the hope is is that Marco will not
continue to be petty
though this is the first time they've
seen each other in the same room so it's
understandable that they can slide into
their old habits
and for corn my coat that just means
arguing that's just the way they say I
miss you
it is their way of saying I really miss
you I'm sorry for all the things that I
did not do
like reaching out to you
as much as Cora has evolved as a
character like she's been through this
big
crucible she still has a lot to that
adorable ball headedness
whenever we do get a lot of mccaw right
during book to I always enjoyed the
scenes with them
arguing more than I do with the scenes
with them like making out her
being really relationship be just feels
much closer to what a normal teenage
relationship would be like
teenagers are supposed to yell at each
other not supposed to be super Zen
that actually brings up an interesting
point about how all the characters are
right now
I think they're around the age like 19
or 20 at this point
just to bring it into the real world
think of them as being like college-age
like twenty-somethings at this point
number three team core reunion
part 2 so this is where all the action
was this is where they really slid back
into all teen cora modem
car chases and kicking butt we also get
to see some accords new abilities at
play
her using spiritual energy to locate
people she's in the spare bike the first
time but when he's in the train station
she doesn't need them at all I think
this beard binds just heightened that
ability
so theoretically she could use that
anywhere she is like she would need
speared binds to look at someone
it is more precise when there are spared
binds around we also see her metal
bender in the chase scene I know
everyone was wondering why she did metal
bending her fight with kubera
I think that just because she was
offered game like she was completely
unprepared
I think getting her ass handed to her
was something that needed to happen like
it was the big wake-up call that she
needed
and a lot of people but that might
happen when she was with top but that
was really just shaking around to the
funk
she was still really disconnected from
the real world when she met could be a
is a member she's been out the loop for
three years they do not have Internet in
the world about our
I don't serve Eric will find a way to
invented gonna be the villain for Cora
book five in the comics
it'll be like the avatars version of the
Internet just address the animation
during the chase scene it becomes pretty
evident that they've really up their
game
it's a blender CG with the cars moving
around but when they're in the train
if you like Kors model it just the most
beautiful than it's ever been
to the shot her face even this brandy
Pete's I mean it's meant to be funny
too because she's reacting to prince who
but it's one the most beautifully
animated scenes that i've seen
at least ever faced so far it take you
could take a screen cap in this
just hanging on your wall and it would
look like a painting if I didn't think
that back on wouldn't sue me at
existence
I would two leaders upload videos a
core reaction faces all the time the
conclusion the chase
is also the moment team core up actually
reunites I mean they met before
but they had really reunited they're
still kinda reconnecting it's that big
hug that's the moment when they come
together
also another great cora Prince movie
moment I just love that her hand as the
want to push him away
if you like this is the best evidence
pic or is not a dumb character
yes you make mistakes but she's is the
only able to recognize prince who as the
douchebag
vidios and shown him in the proper way
also in case you didn't catch a train
was headed to all my shoe
which might give us some clues about
where course headed next
there was that seen in the trailer where
she goes up to the temple
it's possible that that's where that
white motors temple is and a lot of
people are theorizing it might be the
years prison
I don't know that's the case but am
hoping that it is all much you
number two bowling in very do something
good for change
so should start by saying own appear to
have the smartest
but damn its characters on the show but
that on purpose
we're just watching bowl in slowly wake
up to the way the world really works
very nice call back to him being a movie
star if you like bones been acting like
he's been
in a mover this whole time he just
hasn't realized that it's a propaganda
film
propaganda films are primarily made to
misinform people about what's really
going on
it's like Nazi propaganda films they
tell the story hitler wants to tell
not the one that's actually going on the
better they ran into tell them what's
really going on
everyone who's not a nerd nation citizen
is being put into concentration camps
just more world war two imagery pushing
the fact that her soldiers here look
like Nazi stormtroopers anyway
very creepy also as predicted by Lynn
berry
heading back to Republic City to tell
everyone what's going on with the weapon
during their big save on as is big here
a moment know we have to say these
people I feel like this is the giant
corner that his character's turned
very important moment also what a badass
lava bending
the other really important thing you
need to notice is very explosion the mic
ivers
the magnetic machine or axes really EMP
when he was first putting it together
I thought it was going to be a giant
electromagnet it was just gonna pull the
machines back to the wall
but affected the MP is even better which
means they can make just a giant Virgin
over to take out all the Mex
if you didn't see my last video I said
I'm basically expecting could be ready
to march on Republic City net
that is after she gets done in the swamp
in my number one WTF moment kubera is
going to cannibalize
the swamp for all the spear Bynes top is
going to be so
appears when she finds could be right
coming up the danube rotary
this is actually one of my earlier
predictions I wasn't really sure if it
was going to happen
the brakes said the top was coming back
into the story they were like to stay
tuned there's going to be more top
one of the few ways I thought she could
be brought back into the story
is it could be read tried to take this
month they were really clear
about the distinction between the trees
in the swamp
in the spear binds but apparently the
same thing for their part the same
family a
plant life I like the explanation that
the vines in the swamp are much richer
with spiritual energy den the vines in
Republic City I think they'll explain
why that is but
I think that the being you grow tree is
connected to the World Tree
in the spirit world if you like they're
gonna say it's like the same treat it
manifest onto planes of existence
if you like this is the moment break
intended for the fan and return again
Scooby ra
at this point it was very ambiguous she
was doing a very good thing prince who
was a total douchebag
but now cutting down the danube 03 clear
sign that you are a villain
the big question now is what is top
going to do about it
if you actually gonna kick the shit
outta those mixed first add to that she
is the world's most proficient
metal bender she's the OG metal bender
she even said that lyndon seein who are
amazing mental benders
never learned it quite small she thought
they could which means that she's like
on a whole other level
that being said let me know what your
favorite moment was and what do you
think the top
is gonna do now is she gonna be in the
next episode unless the next episode is
exclusively in Republic City
if you like they're gonna have to follow
up with a top moment where he learns
about what's going on at the bank rotary
and remember it's not just the being
grow tree the Cougars coming down
she's going to go down the entire swap
overall I give the absurd us on a plus
but my favorite episode so far
just because are the consequences that
are implied make brandt said something
really funny during interview
where they said did for all the
complaints that the fandom has about
things that cord as the way the
characters act things that are done and
not done
in the plot largely the time those
complaints are made
the questions have already been answers
because the nature of animation because
they have to work so far ahead
did IP finish book for the fish writing
it a long time ago
before we ever saw book 3 that's just
the writing I mean a mission takes over
time but the story is done once they
finish the script
things that pop who core get your shit
together what top is up to with The Last
Airbender characters are up to
all those questions have been answered
he said as they wrap book for update
basically
addressed every major think that they'd
set up every major plot point everything
gets wrapped up by the end before
so any big question you have top baby
daddies yugos wife
the new Fire Lord other things all
answered and everyone's wondering about
Kors past lives to take that the big
hanging question I feel like that will
be answered in the finale or by the
finale
to talk about the animation to aside
from like the big crowd scenes with had
to use a lot a CD duplication
I feel like book for has been the most
beautiful book ever
it's like you can pause any frame up an
episode
and it could be this beautiful painting
hanging on your wall even when
characters are in foreground like when
course face
is really big in the frame the
background still look amazingly
beautiful
another been a lot a comment about Kors
new look especially with getting your
hair did
I personally think that she's beautiful
a lot of that has to do with the way
she's animated in addition to the actual
look itself
I'll be really interesting to see if
chorus haircut kit is on in real life
like you see a budget women walking
around with chorus here
actually core kinda reminded me gogo
from big heroes 6 in this episode
with their here in just her general
attitude like that short cropped look
is going to be that the new look for
badass female characters now
overall amazing up is that if you like
it did amazing job
telegraphing what the action is going to
be in the next couple episodes
like a very clear path for Team cora
against Canberra
understand by saying do not worry about
to be in you grow tree
there will be a reckoning and its name
is top payphone
it's gonna happen next week be sure to
subscribe to my video
I will be posting a CUNY for this
tomorrow you can click here to get that
allowed inefficiencies are posted
in you can click here for my core
episode 6 video thank you so much
watching so top high five
and say a prayer for the mangrove tree